exploration was once cold war and space
race but that's all history now it's
about resources beyond planet Earth and
discovery of worlds yet to come Carnegie
Mellon robots have been on land sea air
underwater and underground the next
right destination is space we are the
only university affiliated with the team
going to the moon as machines and
computers increasingly influenced
day-to-day life the intersection of
natural intelligence and artificial
intelligence will continue to play a
huge role so we frame this conversation
in Davos in several sessions by talking
about how to bring the two together one
of the things that's most exciting about
being here in Davos is the welcome that
we've received for the message of
integration between people and
technology and how essential that
integration is to a healthy future for
all of us in one of the CMU sessions and
iPad Mini was to use to control the
rover in real time and the ipad mini was
passed around to the audience from davos
switzerland there over that's moving
around currently in a simulated moon
landscape moving forward from davos we
look forward to further shaping the
entire field of robotics and its impact
on all the global citizens and many many
scientific discoveries that are yet to
come
you